cette fillette marche sur un pont
construit dix générations avant elle
un pont vivant
[Musique]
la nouvelle
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut marcher plusieurs heures dans la
jungle pour atteindre le village de nom
grillât et ces merveilleuses passerelle
de racine vivante combinaison de la
force de la nature et du génie de
l'homme et le figuier caoutchouc est un
arbre à croissance rapide
ses racines aériennes sont nombreuses et
solides
ces structures naturelles sont réalisés
sans clou ni ficelles les ponts peuvent
mesurer 30 mètres et supporter le poids
de 50 personnes
le village est trop reculer pour y
transporter des matériaux de
construction lourds et les ponts de
cuivre et de bambous s'abîme trop vite
ici cette région du nord-est de l'inde
est une des plus humides de la planète
on y enregistre des records mondiaux de
précipitations dix fois plus de pluie
qu'à montréal
sans répondre à sin les villages de la
tribu seraient séparés les uns des
autres pendant les mois de la mousson
quand les rivières sont en crue
il a fait mourir la patience est une
vertu et les cases ils ont bien compris
la tribu ne craint pas le temps qui
passe mais au contraire en tirent profit
les ponts de racines se développe et se
renforce avec le temps un cas ci peut
travailler sur le même projet que ses
grands parents sans jamais les avoir
connus de leur vivant non pas au lit et
son fils ronald sun travaille sur un
nouveau bond racines dans la forêt à la
frontière du bangladesh
ce chantier demande de l'entretien
durant des décennies et que le père ne
verra probablement jamais la fin de ce
travail mais son fils oui narbonne
d'intenses kénitra dignité et aubergines
à la saddam avance en a marre perche
n'ont pas d'amis ici non
les passerelles de racine vivante des
cas ci ce sont des ponts vers l'avenir
un legs aux prochaines générations pour
qu'elles n'oublient pas leurs racines